on s'amusait toute la journée au bureau
avec 7 appelé à la mode us faith alors
je vous ai mis bien sûr dans les
réflexes
j'ai commencé par raymond raymond j'ai
voulu le voir en justin bieber a beau
regarder tout lui même
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour soi les bottes bien oui c'est clair
je te jure que ça va les chevaux soient
les bonnes questions
il a bien aujourd'hui faut vraiment se
poser les bonnes questions
late late on l'a pensé si l'éclaircie
ses cheveux car oui j'adore j'adore
alors dîner présidé comme qui fait clés
dont il ya toutes les bandes dans més la
vallée d'olt et céda coiffure qu'on va
faire on a également gilles verdez à moi
j'ai voulu te mettre parce que je les
aime et qu'elle vient nous voir la
semaine prochaine
le 24 septembre sera avec nous j'ai
voulu de m
[Applaudissements]
c
là c'est pas mal j'ai voulu y mettre
c'est tranquille on châtie rapprochement
ça change pas beaucoup c'est les mêmes
[Applaudissements]
ben ali
remettez-le abena hommes étaient là ils
me mettaient leur menace
aulas est venu à nîmes quel est le bon
bah c'est d'application ouais normal
vous n'êtes pas encore plus belle que
sur l'application oui oui non je dis des
conneries vous êtes magnifique non mais
franchement
voilà j'ai presque envie d'en voir
francesca francesca on vous a mis au
repos
elvis presley
[Musique]
toujours lui ressemble
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si vous attendez tous rené malleville
regarde et géraldine maillet j'ai
rapidement
on l'a mise en julien doré
[Musique]
ok
mais c'est pas mal ça tombe bien ça fit
bien non c'est pas mal bien d'aller fed
je te griffon aller car les chéris ya
des domaines où les pays bas ont la
remise en jeu donne à regarder
[Musique]
sa fille bien en fonction c'est pas mal
c'est vrai complot
j'ai un cadeau vous émettez le new homes
et remettez nous gérons
je me
[Applaudissements]
on a tous été choqués faire mentionner
que je crois que c'est le meilleur
le passé des remous et
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
et moi je croque avec un mois alain
talents d'où elle savait que c'est
l'artiste conseil qui vend le plus à
l'étranger
en ce moment c'est vraiment c'est un
câlin charisme à la prestance et un
carton voilà je suis fier on est fiers
pour être vraiment j'aime beaucoup ce
qui en a beaucoup qui l'a qui la
critique non on aime bien qu'ils nous
restent à beauchamp michel nerfs après
bien sûr avec moi des mâles ville dans
la culture des valves in tant d'autres
[Rires]
non mais je pense que ça peut changer
on vous a mis en alizés regardez
ce sens
[Applaudissements]
c'est que j'ambitionne hier je sais plus
mais c'est horrible
il n'existait pas lui qui sait que les
twittos ce vote
bien sûr et
[Applaudissements]
nom d'alain tous les matins c'est moi
j'avais des touches par mois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas du tout c'est ce qu'on m'a dit mais
j'ai dit oui ça va ya pas de soleil sur
pato kona il ya beaucoup de lumière on
dirait le public il ya des chiffres et
des lettres vous êtes réveillé
[Applaudissements]
vous oui merci beaucoup c'est loin et de
guerre dont il revient et tu t'étais où
chez sa grand mère
[Applaudissements]
un showmatch monaco monaco y aller
retour avec tagro mais vous avez fait
quoi là bas je sais que je savais qu'une
boîte de communication
j'avais conseil quelqu'un est en à
flaine d'allers retours dans la journée
et j'avoue que c'est crevant et ça c'est
formidable
ouais c'est formidable ce week-end de la
thune
[Applaudissements]
m
beyoncé
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est la vie ça va vite ça parce qu'une
telle émission
alévêque et puis je vais rester rendez
ma vie pour la fin moi je me suis pas vu
apparemment ils m'ont mis en demis
roussos
non alors nous avons trouvé que le mec
qui me ressemblait plus ici c'est
wolverine des x men
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
là tu te dis c'est pas le quota chinois
ces bulbes au tajine holla holla mur car
à lucia ni la grenade
je peux regarder la bouteille
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
ni le
franchement c'est génial à il était
brillante et celui-ci qui les
chiraquiens là il paraît qu'on a moins
que shakira aussi ça oui oui encore là
c'est trop bien
[Musique]